if you're an Alice in Wonderland fan
you're gonna love the newest Descendants
movie Descendants the rise of red
doesn't have an official release date
but we've got plenty of info and behind
the scenes details about this movie to
tide you over until it finally premieres
descendants fans know that the third
movie in the franchise came to a fairly
Final close and by the looks of it it
seemed that the Beloved characters had
told their story in full the barrier
will come down yes this made the fourth
film's plot and which characters it
would follow all the more mysterious to
fans as well as it seems the folks
making it and they laid the mystery on
even thicker since the title was
originally kept under wraps and the film
was only called descendants 4. did you
hear what is it the title of our movie
is the rise of bread the movie has
officially been titled Descendants the
rise of red and that gives us quite a
bit of info about what this movie will
really be about and which characters the
franchise will now be following the
titular red is a new character she's the
daughter of the Queen of Hearts the
other new Leading Lady Chloe happens to
be Cinderella's daughter and sure we're
not used to the queen of hearts and
Cinderella being brought together in one
single fairy tale but that's what we've
come to expect from this franchise after
all in red and Chloe's case the unlikely
pairing comes together to travel back in
time and save auradon they accomplish
said time travel thanks to the white
rabbit's pocket watch hence the movie's
original title the pocket watch as for
what exactly this will entail it's
really anyone's guess but we do know
that there will be familiar faces as
well as new ones and there will also of
course be all the fun dancing and
singing The Descendants fans certainly
expect oh and there will also be plenty
of action descendants for his low-key in
action film because I'm doing stunts and
also it's such a heavy dance film this
film will revolve around two new
characters red and Chloe and it seems
that they'll be an unlikely pairing
since red is a rebel and Chloe is well
the exact opposite she prefers to listen
to her royal parents and strive for
Perfection since it's Red's mother the
Queen of Hearts who's putting the world
in danger however this Dynamic will
surely work out in everyone's favor the
pair will have an unusually common goal
since she's the movie's namesake it's
safe to say that descendants fans will
be seeing their fair share of red in
this next era of the franchise red will
be played by none other than Kylie
Cantrell who plays another articular
Disney character in Gabby Duren and the
unsittables she says that she relates to
her upcoming character red she's very
witty sarcastic and very just like makes
her own rules and doesn't do things the
typical way and her relationship to her
character aside she was thrilled to get
a role in the franchise that she knows
and loves I remember literally watching
this franchise ever since I was nine
years old so a pinch me moment as for
Chloe Charming she'll be played by Malia
Baker who played Marianne in Netflix's
the babysitters club series yes these
leading ladies are sure to get this film
off on their right foot while red and
Chloe are clearly going to be important
parts of descendants the rise of red
there are plenty of other new faces
joining the cast too Rita Ora is a
surprising addition to the cast as Red's
mom aka the Queen of Hearts while she's
appeared on the big screen in things
like the 50 Shades of Gray franchise and
Pokemon detective Pikachu she's
primarily a singer-songwriter and we
have a feeling that this will play a big
role in the film this movie will also
show many characters in their youth this
will include Bridget aka the Queen of
Hearts before she got the title who will
be played by Ruby Rose Turner Young
Cinderella will be played by Morgan
Dudley young Maleficent will be played
by Mars and young Aladdin and Jasmine
will be played by Kabir Berry and Eliza
Azar respectively uma's sister
uliana will also be a new face played by
another High School Musical the musical
the series Alum Dara Renee and it's
clear that like Kylie she'll be doing
plenty of her own stunts as well
Juliana's sister Uma will once again be
played by China Anne McClain and it's
clear that these leading ladies are
psyched to be part of this highly
anticipated project We Begin filming
early next year everybody and we can't
wait for y'all to see it as for one new
character who we don't know much about
that would be the mystery royal baby
who's promised to be an important plot
point in the film any guesses about who
that might be while the royal baby may
be a mystery there's one Royal who
certainly isn't hi this is Brandy and I
play Cinderella one of the most highly
anticipated parts of the upcoming movie
is Brandy's return as Cinderella 26
years after she played the role in the
iconic 1997 film Rogers and
Hammerstein's Cinderella promo photos
show the star looking as Royal as ever
and with some interesting blue hair and
it's clear already that Brandy still has
that same amazing chemistry with her
on-screen hubby from decades ago hi I'm
Paulo montalbon I play King charming and
welcome to set yes Prince Charming from
1997's Rogers and Hammerstein Cinderella
it's gotten a bit of promotion but he's
still the prince charming we know and
love Paolo montabon is also reprised his
role but this time he's King Charming
he's still opposite Brandy though and
fans are definitely here for it I think
I've ever told you this you literally
changed my life doing that food cheese
right and it seems they're as excited as
we are that they'll most likely be
singing together again our voices
together just it just was so magical
yeah it really was yeah it's such great
memories from that time huh we did we
were kids we were and now they have kids
well in Descendants the rise of red they
do anyway and we're excited to see
Cinderella and Prince whoops we mean
King Charming with a child and of course
singing together again as far as we know
Brandy and Paulo are the only cast
members from Rogers and Hammerstein
Cinderella who are joining the cast of
descendants the rise of red that said
there are characters from the previous
three descendants movies that will be
returning interestingly Ursula's
daughter
Uma will be the only main character from
previous movies returning as a main
character again in addition to some
teenage versions of familiar characters
the film will be joined by Joshua Cauley
reprising the role of hook Melanie
Paxson as the Fairy Godmother Jeremy
Swift as principal Merlin and Leonardo
NAMM as Maddox Hatter who it sounds like
will have quite a significant role in
this heavy Alice in Wonderland inspired
installment now descendants fans know
that the soundtrack of these movies has
to be one of the most important elements
that makes descendants what it is so
what will this installment soundtrack
include well as of now we don't know
much about the ins and outs of the
musical setlist what we do know is that
this film will include seven brand new
original songs as well as of course some
Disney Classics we simply have to get
Cinderella and King Charming singing
something from the Cinderella soundtrack
right right it's also worth noting that
since the Queen of Hearts is such a big
focus of this film and she happens to be
played by none other than Rita Ora we
have a feeling that this will have a bit
to do with what ends up on the
soundtrack whatever songs may get into
Descendants the rise of red we can't
wait to start listening it's safe to say
that we can't wait for a lot of aspects
of this fourth descendants installment
it makes it pretty hard to believe that
this movie almost didn't happen fans of
the films all remember the tragic loss
of 20 year old Cameron Boyce who played
one of the main characters Carlos in the
original movies the Cliffhanger ending
of the third movie that would have set
audiences up for a fourth installment
wasn't ultimately included and the
characters we came to love seemed to
live happily ever after even the
original cast members believed that the
franchise was complete and this was a
logical conclusion since Sans Carlos it
would have been difficult to proceed
with the storyline consequently Dove
Cameron Booboo Stewart and Sophia Carson
couldn't return as Mal and Evie for this
reason the minds behind the franchise
decided to move forward with the fourth
movie with a new cast of characters
since they didn't want to work on the
film without their late cast mate
Cameron whether this is true or not Dove
Cameron did Express this sentiment in
the past I don't love the idea of doing
it without Cameron I don't know what it
would look like
um but I also love the franchise would
these cast members return in the future
there's nothing that I can say for sure
but I definitely can say that it is not
out of the question yeah for now it
seems that that story has come to a
close but we're all looking forward to
the new cast of characters whose
descendant story is just beginning are
you as glad as we are that they decided
to continue The Descendants franchise
are you more excited to see the
returning characters or the new ones
let's talk about it in the comments and
for more videos like this one be sure to
like And subscribe to the things
[Music]